it's been a little while since we have
followed up with another entry in our
series of videos calling out fake quotes
that are widely shared on the internet
often
uncritically and we've done several
other stoic authors it's about time that
we get to the most prolific stoic author
that we have and that is Sena there's a
lot of fake quotes that people will
uncritically share even on stoicism
sites so let's start with the first and
most egregious one religion is regarded
by the common people as true by the wise
as false and by rulers as useful and you
notice that this one is coming directly
from the stoicism decom who clearly
didn't bother to sort their quotes or
check on any of them and is this by
senica no as a matter of fact this very
cynical observation which by the way
cisero has a character say something
like this in on the nature of the Gods
is actually coming from Edward Gibbon a
much much later author who wrote the
various modes of worship which prevailed
in the Roman world were all considered
by the people as equally True by the
philosophers equally false and by the
magistrate as equally useful so you can
see that people are actually reducing
the equally out of there into this
condensed quote this is from the history
of the decline and fall of the Roman
Empire which by the way not very good
history at all a little bit later on
researching it Albert hubard would claim
in little Journeys to the homes of great
philosophers that Gibbon was making a
quote free translation from senica and
free translation there should be
understood as putting anything he wanted
into senica's mouth this second fake
quote is a very popular one especially
among business types and you notice that
this one is actually coming from what
should be viewed as a typically
reputable website the I AI right and
they didn't bother to check their quotes
you know a lot of these institutions
have budgets where they could easily
hire a fact Checker before they put
things out there did senica say nothing
remotely like this no senica actually
does talk about the need for Preparation
he doesn't use opportunity quite so much
you know is more common to think in
terms of like the appropriate time among
the Ancients but he does talk about a
wrestler who has trained and prepared
paired and and those sorts of things but
there's nothing about luck in there so
it looks like the oldest instance of a
quote like this might be from the early
1900s in youth's companion he is lucky
who realizes that luck is the point
where preparation meets opportunity and
it's ATT tributed to other people as
well it gets passed around and shared
and now I think they just Tack senica
and aim onto it basically to have some
sort of prestige associated with the
saying another very popular quote that
you'll see there's no right way to do
the wrong thing or a wrong thing there's
variations of this out there and really
the first attestation of this looks like
it's from 1850 in an article about
Britain and IND India published in
daal's southern and western review
criticizing Britain's treatment of India
and writing there's no right way of
doing a wrong thing while the relation
itself is allowed to continue the mode
of acting under this relation must
partake of its vicious and unnatural
character and then we see it getting
reprinted here and there particularly in
newspapers the Negro star in 1947 a set
of wise sayings and then 1955 it gets
credited to the philosopher senica in a
Louisiana newspaper who knows where this
is actually coming from originally you
know in terms of the attribution to Sena
was it something that the Louisiana
newspaper writer had seen somebody else
attribute we don't know but it's clearly
from the
1900s this quote we are waved of the
same sea leaves of the same tree flowers
of the same Garden sounds very nice
doesn't it it is not from senca at all
although interestingly there's a little
bit of a backstory there about monuments
in Italy that are supposed to be a
message of Fraternity in the province of
Verona these are supposed to be inspired
by the philosopher senica but in point
of fact we know exactly where this comes
from it is from the founder of the bahai
faith in the 19th century bahua recorded
in his promulgation of universal peace
so this one is pretty easy to identify
as definitively not being from senica
even though it's constantly getting
attributed to him this next one is kind
of an interesting one because it's not
totally off base Sonica says something
kind of like this but he doesn't say
this specifically and notice who is
putting this quote out there Franklin
cvy right the company of Steven cvy and
he put this actually out in his Twitter
again without checking his sources
without hiring somebody to do the basic
fact checking that would be so easy to
do anger is an acid that can do more
harm to the vessel in which it is stored
than to anything on which it is report
this is a common statement made by a lot
of people it's also attributed to Mark
Twain it appears in the American Mercury
volume 92 and word for word like that
it's also attributed to the Baptist
Beacon which is another publication now
did senica say something kind of like
this yes but senica doesn't talk about
acid he talks about poison
right evil herself drinks the largest
portion of her own poison poison is kind
of like acid but not exactly the same
and so we have to call this a fake quote
and people should probably not be
attributing this one to senica anymore
now we get one that's very interesting
because people who share this almost
never share just the English it's
somehow very attractive to share the
Latin perhaps to show their erudition or
to establish some kind of bonafide and
so let's actually read the
Latin diabolicum to air is human but to
persist in error is diabolical is this
by senica no it's not by senica who we
do see saying things like this before
senica and after Sena cisero says
something like like this right and
Austine of Hippo says something like
this as well and then we see something
much later with Alexander Pope's essay
on criticism where he says to air as
human to forgive Divine now it would
kind of make sense to talk about
diabolical for Augustine Augustine is a
Christian Author uh it could even make
sense for some Pagan authors in late
Antiquity as well really wouldn't make
sense for CIS or for senica to be
talking about that although they both
you know would say persevering
persisting in error that is indeed a
problem so the attributing this to
diabolical influences that's more of a
early Christianity late Antiquity sort
of thing this next one he who spares the
wicked injures the good a decent
sentiment a interesting proverb but it's
not by senica rather it is from pilus
Cirus and uh we see similar things said
by somebody like Cicero in on duties but
the point of fact of this is that it
doesn't come from senica it does come
from another identifiable author so we
probably shouldn't be attributing it to
Sena himself here's a very interesting
Pro opposition love in its Essence is
spiritual fire now if you know anything
about ancient culture if you know
anything about the vocabulary the
concepts that they would be using you
can say right off the bat this is not
only not from senica it's not from any
ancient Greek or Latin author these are
some pretty modern ideas maybe you could
find some of them in the Middle Ages as
well you know love being a spiritual
fire yeah that's not going to be in
somebody like senica who is it from
Emmanuel swedenborg who you know is kind
of a Mystic and a very popular writer
and this is rather a let's call it ear
romantic sentiment not something senica
himself would
say here's another that you see
used quite often and attributed to
senica every sin is the result of a
collaboration we know who this comes
from it's Steven crane in the blue Hotel
not from senica at all and I'm not sure
at all of the backstory of how this got
attributed to senica himself but we know
that it's not by
him I've saved what in certain respects
is the best for last throw me to the
wolves and I will return leading the
pack so it's not clear where this came
from but this is clearly like a 20th or
21st century sort of thing to say full
of bravado not remotely what somebody
who practices stoicism would think to
themselves let alone say to other people
but it is the kind of you know stoic bro
type of sentiment event that you do see
circulated around quite a bit by people
who don't understand stoicism but think
that it's all about toughness the idea
of throwing somebody to the wolves do
you really think you're going to have a
Latin author talking about that I mean
senica does talk about throwing somebody
to lampies or eels to Feast on them
saying that this is a horrible thing
that somebody is doing and is punished
by the emperor a Justice for in on anger
but where would you be throwing somebody
to the Wolves this is a much later
saying and sentiment and so definitely
not by senica no idea who actually
coined this but this falls under the
province of silly nonsense so clearly
not something senica would have ever had
said even if he was just perhaps joking
around because it's so foreign to his
mindset as always I will close by
stressing that I think we have an
obligation if we're going to throw
quotes around to actually check to see
whether those quotes can be sourced you
should be suspicious of people who in
social media or on websites or videos or
podcasts or even books these days are
quoting Sena or other authors without
saying where the pan message is coming
from if you don't know whether a quote
is fake or real you probably shouldn't
be reposting it yourself because you're
just contributing to the problem then
and you know you should demand sources
it's perfectly fine to say where in in
senas or who whoever else's Works did
this come from and I've got two sites
I'd like to recommend to you sententia
antiqui and quote investigator both of
which are quite useful for theing out
and discussing the Providence if we do
know it of the many fake quotes that
circulate
around